[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le trème barrage qui aura cédé en
1963 celui de Baldwin Mills à quelques
kilomètres de Los Angeles par miracle la
découverte de la brèche à son début a
permis de donner l'alarme end pour
permettre l'évacuation sinon on se
demande combien de victimes on aurait pu
compter sous les tonnes d'eau qui se
sont déversé dans la vallée et qui
emportèrent maisons et voitures comme
des coques de
noix 1 million et demi de mè CUB d'eau
potable destinée à l'alimentation de la
région avait disparu par l'énorme
ouverture au-delà de laquelle quelques
heures plus tard on ne devait plus
trouver qu'un spectacle de
désolation
toute une vallée enfouie dans la boue
200 maisons détruite 2000 plus ou moins
réduite à l'état de ruine mais malgré
l'étendue des dégâts matériels on ne
peut s'empêcher de penser qu'un désastre
du genre de celui de langaron a pu être
évité à Berlin Noël ait lever de
tristesse que jette sur la ville le mur
élevé depuis plus de 2 ans par milliers
60000 personnes par jour les Berlinois
de l'Ouest ont pris d'assaut 12 bureaux
habilités à leur délivrer des laisser
passer pour se rendre de l'autre
[Musique]
côté pour 400000 hommes femmes et
enfants de tous âgees c'était enfin la
possibilité de revoir des êtres chers
que quelques centaines de mètres parfois
ont suffi à séparer depuis 2 ans on a
donc pratiqué quelques brèches dans ce
mur qui isole les deux parties d'une
même ville mais aussi sépare des
familles pour Noël et les fêtes du
Nouvel An du moins ces familles ont pu
se retrouver la trêve pour quelques
jours leur a permis de goûter ensemble
comme partout les joies particulières de
ce temps de
rémission à l'Élysée le ministre de la
Santé Publique monsieur rayond Marcelin
a présenté au général de Gaulle les
délégués des pays qui ont accepté de
participer à la création d'un organisme
international de lutte contre le cancer
une initiative française on s'en
souvient à laquelle le chef de l'État a
donné son plein
appui pour la première fois depuis 10
ans députés et sénateurs se sont
retrouvés à Versailles le dernier
congrès s'est en effet réuni en 1953
pour l'élection du successeur de
Monsieur Vincent Orial à la présidence
de la République et se termina au bout
de 8 jours par l'élection de René cotti
cette fois la réunion des 757 membres du
Congrès avait un plus mince objectif
celui de modifier les dates des sessions
du Parlement le président de l'Assemblée
monsieur Chaband Delmas a présidé comme
le veut la Constitution cette réunion de
l'Assemblée et du Sénat et la réforme
favorable à un meilleur établissement
des travaux parlementaire a été adopté
sans difficulté à une confortable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
majorité à ceux qui ne verront même pas
les lumières de Noël donnons aujourd'hui
une pensée à ces petits aveugles qu'un
certain frère Louis installa à la
persagotière voici plus de
oness de fa oublier le solitude en les
intégrant au monde des
hommes tu vas l la lre C première
ligne là une centaine d'enfants entre 8
et 14 ans apprennent selon le système
bra à lire et
écrire en bas à droite au milieu à
gauche
vas-y étrange spectacle d'une classe où
dans un crépitement de pointe crevant le
papier tendu se déroule la plus insolite
des leçons
[Applaudissements]
d'écriture le fleuve le plus long de
France la mais ils connaont comme vous
le cours de la Loire la place des villes
le tracé des
frontièresour et voici peut-être le plus
étrange la leçon de
géométrie au point C vous tracerez une
parallèle au côté
AB
[Applaudissements]
science vivant à ces jeunes êtres privés
de la vue s'ouvre quand même le domaine
de la
connaissance de chaque côté oreillette
gauche et orillette droite et les
ventricules les cavités plus étroites à
l'intérieur tapissé de ces muscles qui
sont représentés ici mais c'est surtout
la musique que pour la plupart il
cultive vers la musique qu'on les guide
et si les notes n'ont pas pour eux la
même forme que pour nous l'univers
sensible de la musique développe les
mêmes enchantements la même ouverture
sur le
monde jou la gamme de sol sol Maje
peut-être difficile à supporter d'abord
la leçon de violon est sans doute la
vision la plus extraordinaire et le
signe de cette sorte de miracle qu est
la réussite d'une
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aventure
4 2 3
[Applaudissements]
4 3
[Musique]
4 car c'est le signe qu'ils sont rentrés
dans la vie ces enfants aveugles auqu
les hommes ont réussi à ouvrir le monde
où nous vivons
[Musique]
elle est venue comme chaque année depuis
bientôt 200 ans cette fête de Noël que
les peintres depuis philippol Lippi ont
répété sur d'innombrables toiles cette
histoire merveilleuse de l'Enfant Jésus
né dans les tables réchauffé par le bœuf
et l'âne cette histoire en luminée par
la légende à laquelle chacun mêle ce
qu'il y a de plus pur l'honneur de la
pauvreté la grandeur de la solitude et
l'idée de la paix entre les hommes Noël
c'est aussi le décor que les vieux
peintres flamands ont teinté de
sentiments l'hiver blanc le village dans
son silence autour de l'église dont les
cloches vont sonner c'est encore
l'évocation des réveillons heureux dont
Chardin allume les reflets dans cette
vision de fruits de coquillage et de
Caraf ce festin qu'on trouve au centre
de la plus longue nuit de l'année
comme au centre des joies familiales ce
réveillon qui est à un soup banal ce
qu'est Noël aux autres
nuits revenons par ces chemins de neige
à la grande leçon de Noël qui est le
miracle de l'enfant car à l'échelle
humaine comme dans le tableau de George
de l tour Noël c'est aussi l'histoire
simple et magnifique de la femme qui met
au monde un enfant l'enfant attendu
révéré fêté même chez les plus humbles
même chez les plus durs l'enfant qui
apaise les visages et fait terre les
rancœurs l'enfant qui donne l'espoir
d'un monde plus vrai plus beau plus sage
le monde de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Noël